so we've known for a long time that
you've got comedic chops you're a very
funny guy great timing do we get to see
that in bumblebee well I know we're
still working on a movie it's not
exactly finished yet we're gonna show
some more footage today yeah they may or
may not have some takes that they can
use see see now between you Travis Haley
who was the biggest transformers nerd on
I've seen trucks 200,000 gallons yes
what certain certainly a fan as a child
yeah especially because the two-for-one
the Transformers are true choice for one
and their slogan more that meets the eye
as a child it really was so it was like
you had this magic in your hands and it
was real
Travis's transformers geek which he
should be because he's captaining our
ship I really loved the fact that I had
an opportunity to do something different
I've done certain things on screen I've
done certain things live performing in
w/e and this offered me a chance to do
something new
we love your back and forth with BTS
about being their bodyguard yeah and I
couldn't see you when you did the Korean
leg of promo for this you're gonna bring
them along with you that is well beyond
my control
they are truly in their own universe I
mean they have created their own
universe and I really think that that's
special I was telling another
interviewer earlier so I was introduced
to BTS by almost like a happy accident I
began to follow j-hope and then begin to
follow the band I listen to their music
I enjoy their music but I most enjoy the
passion they invoke in their fans yeah
the fanbase globally yeah is so diehard
and coming from a WB fan base where it's
like the same thing like they follow the
guys they fall and the women they fall
and they like people and they don't like
people and they're very adamant about
their opinion and they very adamant of
voice their opinion BTS has created that
same phenomenon and I just think it's
extra special it's it's their success is
in parallel well I want to see you and
them together honestly BTS December slam
I wanna see you would really like me in
the background yes I mean if we can see
you at all yeah everybody can see me
yeah and that was that was my whole
pitch I've been drawing them for you